và em đi đó sẽ được phát hình chứ tòn cầu.
Mề dưới thượng cho mắt bẹ thế giới.
Rồi lập, bước mình đã chịt về phát hông bị sự của người Nam,
mà thông qua âm nhạc của các người dưới.
Thì sẽ được còn tháp cho em đi,
thì chúng tôi hướng bên mở đầu cũng như là phần trên khai phát triển của ta phợm
thì hai nghiệp xí, suy điện 2, 2, 2, 2, 2, 2, 2, 2, 2, 1, 3 nhau.
Thì kia xí họ rất khách kia trong người Việt,
một người nước là khó nhìn cả những khoản địa trang phục.
Họ rất yêu khó khách kia và trang phục.
Đến, kích sạch sợp đó rất là răng trong dật.
Họ tục sợp sẽ thử ra, có thể hoa xí triển và nhìn kích kích kích bây giờ,
khó khó khó khó khó khách, trong khi ngại mà quay bị tâm nhé.
Cái mà chúng tôi vừa bù bà phía nó ngàn,
thì xí bió lòng đến đây để đều diễn và ki vình chỉ thật ra,
và rất là phích thú và gần như nó đám triển trong người thung cạnh,
và thương nhiên để người thung người kết tàn của mình.
Họ những cạnh mạ, đi ở trong phu dừng,
Cái khuyên của tôi
Điều có thể đánh bình
And we also want to say a great thank you to all the organizers
And to the charity process by you know,
Good morning Vietnam
It's been great support that course and we're so grateful for the support we have received
I have been so impressed by the professionalism of all the crews
I think each and every single person
All we did is take different sets today
And each and every person played their part that played it so beautifully and quietly and elegantly
The set up between all the shots was so
Efficient and for us as artists that say
Doth a lot of energy, that we could concentrate on performing
And to have that level of professionalism
Between the home through working so amazingly round together
We're really really grateful